hi it's me Michelle from loud muffin
with more science meets beauty I keep
coming across recipes for DIY sunscreen
so I thought I'd make a video about them
there are rumors so store-bought
sunscreens are toxic and may even be
more harmful than the Sun itself so many
people are turning to DIY sunscreens
using what's considered the safest
sunscreen ingredient zinc oxide commonly
called zinc the ingredients of a
store-bought zinc oxide sunscreen look
something like this in Australia active
ingredients linked oxide 15% so you
think that mixing 15% zinc oxide into a
base would give us PS 50 right and
sunscreen can be quite expensive as well
so it's fantastic for your budget that's
what people are thinking when they whip
up a DIY sunscreen recipe that looks
something like this oils zinc oxide
steyr a few tones
sometimes people even slap an SPF label
on it and sell it unfortunately this is
a terrible idea
there's a good freezin that sunscreen is
treated legally as a medicine people put
on sunscreen that's labeled SPF 30 go
into the sun's cancer-causing UV rays
and expect the sunscreen to protect them
because cancer is a pretty big deal most
countries have lots of regulations
around sunscreen think about the other
things that protect you and your loved
ones from death would you put on a
radiation suit you found on Pinterest
before going into a nuclear zone would
you trust a DIY seatbelt a DIY go to
surgery a DIY rollercoaster you found on
your blog please don't say yes in case
you think skin cancer is no big deal
here are some statistics on it two and
three Australians have skin cancers by
70 there's one melanoma death in the US
every hour your risk of melanoma doubles
if you've had more than five sunburns
and daily sunscreen reduces your risk of
squamous cell carcinoma by 40% and
melanomas by 50%
so now that you know how important sun
protection is how do you make sure a
sunscreen works here's where SPF comes
in SPF stands for Sun Protection factor
it tells you how much protection from
Sun bone you get with sunscreen compared
to nothing at all for example with SPF
30 sunscreen your skin can handle 30
times as much UV before burning if you
apply it the right amount UV changes at
the time of day and with clouds so SPF
testing use of special UV lamps in the
lab testing sunscreen on microscope
slides is unreliable so it's tested on
actual human volunteers two milligrams
of sunscreen are applied per square
centimetre of skin for the test there's
also a broad-spectrum requirement in
most places which means that the
sunscreen has a decent level of
protection against UV a sundown is
mostly caused by shorter wavelength UVB
but newer research has found that longer
wavelength UVA is also damaging both
contribute to skin aging and cancer
because proper SPF testing is quite
complicated it costs thousands of
dollars there are other regulations
around drugs and their costs even more
that's part of the reason why sunscreen
is expensive
another reason sunscreen is expensive is
that it's very difficult to make a
product that reliably protects you from
the Sun unfortunately it's more
complicated than just using the right
amount of UV protective ingredients
cosmetic formulators consider sunscreen
one of the most difficult products to
formulate because changing almost any
tiny thing will change the vinyl SPF the
TGA in Australia states in their testing
guidelines the SPS and other physical
properties of the sunscreen are affect
is not only by the active ingredients
but also by the base cosmetic chemists
used the amount of active ingredient as
the starting point for us on screen
there's still a lot of trial and error
before they can make a sunscreen that
works and it's not just working out what
to put in the other 85% there are a ton
of factors to consider when making an
effective sunscreen there are a whole
text books written on it here are some
of the other factors that will affect
SPF distribution is the active in the
sunscreen interactions between different
ingredients the pH of the sunscreen how
the sunscreens be mixed how the
sunscreen applies on skin how the
sunscreen dries on the skin separation
and degradation on the skin settling and
degradation in the bottle over time the
amount of active ingredient is only one
tiny part of the puzzle let's look at
just one factor pH zinc oxide dissolves
below pH 7 and when it's dissolved it
won't give any protection your skin and
sweat are both below pH 7 so the pH of
the sauntering will drop as you're
wearing it Peiper sunscreens are
formulated to avoid this problem you can
see here the different SPS you get with
similar amounts of zinc oxide 15 percent
zinc gives one sunscreen SPF 50 plus 19
percent zinc gives another sunscreen SPF
15 the BASF calculator a tool that
cosmetic chemists use as a starting
point for formulations tells us that 20%
zinc gives us SPF 8 or 13 so there isn't
a straightforward relationship between
the amount of active ingredient and SPF
let's say you've managed to get exactly
the same ingredients as a commercial
zinc oxide sunscreen and you're ready to
mix them together you still won't
necessarily be able to make a sunscreen
that works because just like cooking the
sunscreen ingredients need to be mixed
in the right way
zinc oxide is a particularly annoying
ingredient to use in sunscreens because
it's notorious for clumping up this is a
problem because bigger particles mean
poorer coverage for example if you have
a cherry will cover the area the size of
the cherry but if you smash it up into
juice you can use it to cover a much
larger area even though you've used the
same amount of cherry again 15% zinc
oxide doesn't always give the same
protection here's a table from the zinc
oxide supplier showing the SPF values
you get from two different sizes of
particles even with the same percent
zinc oxide the SPF halves when you
change the particle size most DIY
sunscreen recipes don't recommend the
right size of zinc but even if you buy
the right size of zinc it doesn't mean
all work because when zinc oxide comes
out it turns into bigger particles how
can you stop the zinc oxide from
clumping in commercial sunscreens zinc
is usually coated with ingredients that
make a clump less but DIY sunscreens use
uncoated zinc oxide because the coatings
aren't natural even when coated zinc
oxide requires industrial homogenizers
which are super powered electric mixers
to spread the particles out both of
these sunscreen look even when you apply
them but when you look at them under a
microscope you can see the tiny holes
where you'll get no protection in fact
you can get worse than nerve protection
because oils can increase UV damage zinc
also plumps up and settles over time
even in some commercial sunscreens that
have passed SPF testing so even if you
somehow manage to get the DIY sun's
going to work one time the sunscreen
probably won't be the same when you use
it the second time it can also clump up
as you apply it again the clumping might
not be visible so in summary a
sunscreens effectiveness doesn't depend
on the amount of a single ingredient it
contains it doesn't even depend on the
amount of all the ingredients that
contains
the process of making the sunscreen
makes a big difference too and shaking
it in a jar or using an electric mixer
won't cutter I mean this bowl contains
the same cake ingredients as this
delicious delicious butter but it won't
turn out the same when you bake it
official FPS testing uses human
volunteers but that doesn't mean testing
it on yourself is a good idea the test
needs to be done in a reliable way that
will reflect whether it will be
effective for most people in real life
just like how my grandma smoked like a
chimney have one kidney and live till
ninety a sunscreen that you wore while
not burning isn't necessarily an
effective sunscreen
were there any clouds that day what was
the UV light at that time of year
what was the time as J do you have fun
resistant skin did you go into the shade
how often were you facing so that your
skin was in the shade how much did you
switch the the sunscreen brush against
clothing there are too many variables so
if it worked all you can see is that it
worked for you in that exact situation
once in proper SPF testing they control
for all these variables some phone is
also only one of the effects of UV
sunburn mostly happens due to UVB but
using a still causes cancer pigmentation
and wrinkles even if you don't get birds
using a DIY sunscreen you're potentially
exposing yourself to some serious UVA
damage that you won't know about until
many years later sunscreen may be
expensive but it's expensive because
it's effective and it's much cheaper
than skin cancer
there aren't any studies showing that
front screen chemicals cause more harm
than good
they definitely protect against skin
cancer and aging according to the most
recent studies though some speculation
that sunscreen ingredients can cause
endocrine disruption but the in vitro
and animal studies that found that use
way way more than you'd ever be suppose
to there's also concerned about
nanoparticles but the current evidence
shows that they don't pass through the
skin surface the logic reactions are
real risk though so make sure you patch
test if your skin is sensitive aside
from that the UV protective benefits of
using a proper sunscreen outweigh the
risks
unfortunately DIY fan screen isn't
better than nothing first people stay in
the Sun longer if they think they're
protected so you'd get more sun damage
overall secondly oils don't gives good
sun protection in fact others can
sometimes increase sun damage if there
are microscopic holes in your front
screen you'll have no protection they're
possibly worse than no protection
finally link oxide itself can be a
problem
a lot of DIY recipes tell you to use
uncoated zinc oxide because it's
supposedly more natural but uncoated
zinc oxide is photoreactive
this means that when it's exposed to UV
it will react with other substances to
produce free radicals one of the big
causes of skin damage coating the zinc
oxide stops this from happening while we
don't know whether the amount of free
radicals has a big effect on the skin
your potentially causing extra damage by
wearing diy's sunscreen you might
actually give yourself more sun damage
than wearing nothing at all keeping in
mind the scary skin cancer stats I
showed you earlier this is pretty darn
scary DIY sunscreens are a bad idea
because it's incredibly unlikely that
you've managed to make something that
can reliably protect you from
cancer-causing UV rays and DIY sunscreen
can potentially expose you to more
damage than nothing at all
save DIY for things that don't run the
risk of giving you cancer if you're
still worried about the dangers of
sunscreen then reduce them and practice
some avoidance so in the shade or wear
sun protective clothing or you can
choose to only by sunscreens containing
ingredients you regard as safe don't
repost DIY recipes and encourage other
people to try them even if they work for
you you don't want to be responsible for
their skin cancer if you see people
selling DIY sunscreen illegally you can
report it via the links I've provided in
the caption I hope this video made sense
to you if you enjoyed it please like it
and share it you might also like to
check out my blog watch the other videos
on my channel and subscribe
[Music]
[Music]